Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There is no room for softness, not in Sparta, no place for weakness. Only the hard and the strong may call themselves Spartans. Only the hard, only the strong. The words of Dilios, narrator of the film 300, adapted from Frank Miller's comic book about the Battle of Thermopylae. And those words, of course, apply to one of the Rest is History's presenters. But which?
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。这里没有软弱的余地，斯巴达绝不容许软弱，没有软弱的容身之所。唯有坚毅者和强者方可自称为斯巴达人。唯有坚毅者，唯有强者。这是电影《300勇士》旁白迪利奥斯的话，改编自弗兰克·米勒关于温泉关战役的漫画。这些话当然也适用于《历史的其余部分》的主持人之一。但究竟是谁呢？
Which indeed? Today, we will discover which of us is the hardened Spartan and which the metropolitan Athenian fob. It's so hard to tell so tom i know you know loads about sparta let me be completely frank i know nothing about sparta at all you've just you've just been there right yes uh so you've just come back from the peloponnese i have that's right the fork bit that is attached to the mainland of Greece. Right, the bottom bit of Greece. You can imagine the map. Yeah, the bottom. Sparta is kind of above the bottom. So there are three forks, the one furthest right.
究竟是谁呢？今天，我们将揭晓我们之中谁才是真正的钢铁斯巴达人，而谁又是大都市的雅典花花公子。这太难分辨了，所以汤姆，我知道你对斯巴达了解很多。请恕我直言，我对斯巴达一无所知。你刚刚，你刚刚才去过那里，对吧？是的，呃，所以你刚从伯罗奔尼撒半岛回来。是的，没错。就是连着希腊本土那个像叉子一样的部分。没错，就是希腊南部。你能想象出那张地图。对，南部。斯巴达大概在南部的上方。所以那里有三个叉子，最右边的那一个。
That's right. It sort of commands the plain of Laconia. The Eurotas Valley. We passed through it. So we were in a place called Monemvasia, which is on the coast, which is a Byzantine city for a time and then we were driving to a place that I'm sure you know called Mistras which is another Byzantine city up in the mountains the Tigetos mountains I think they're called and sort of Sparta is just below Mistras the modern Sparta um I have to say it didn't delay
没错。它大概俯瞰着拉科尼亚平原。欧罗塔斯河谷。我们路过那里。所以我们在一个叫莫讷姆瓦夏的地方，它在海岸边，曾是一座拜占庭城市；然后我们开车去了一个我确信你听说过的地方，叫米斯特拉斯，那是群山中的另一座拜占庭城市，我想它们被称为泰格托斯山。斯巴达就在米斯特拉斯的正下方，也就是现代的斯巴达。嗯，我必须说，它并没有耽误我们太久，
us very long because basically it is very modern now you i'm gonna shame you well not shame you because you will be i know you have no shame uh i do you um you you gave me a recommendation while i was away you said there was some temple where people competed for cheese is that right yes um temple of artemis orthea that's right you said it's a chilling site and we should absolutely go and see it so i raised this with my family and there was a general sort of murmur of discontent as people as people said is it just a load of old stones in a field um we know what tom holland likes and then i googled it and the first thing that came up when I googled it was it said,
因为基本上它现在非常现代化。好吧，我要让你感到羞愧——呃，也不是羞愧，因为我知道你没有羞愧之心——我有的，你……你自我离开后给我推荐了一个地方，你说那里有个神庙，人们会在那里抢夺奶酪，对吧？是的，呃，阿尔忒密斯·俄耳提亚神庙，没错。你说这是一个令人毛骨悚然的遗址，我们绝对应该去看看。所以我向家人提出了这个建议，结果大家发出一阵普遍的不满，人们说，这不就是田野里的一堆破石头吗？我们知道汤姆·霍兰喜欢什么。然后我谷歌了一下，我谷歌出来的第一条结果说：
a well-known haunt for local homeless and drug addicts. And so my wife said, that's where Tom Holland is sending us. Absolutely no way. No way. So we didn't go. You didn't go? No, we didn't go.
这是当地无家可归者和瘾君子的著名聚集地。所以我的太太说，这就是汤姆·霍兰要把我们送去的地方。绝对不可能。绝不可能。所以我们没去。你们没去？不，我们没去。
We went for lunch instead, and we had a massive, massive souvlaki on a skewer suspended above our table. Maybe if you remind me i'll tweet a picture of it's a brilliant picture of this enormous quantity of food very well i think the question about i think the question is is answered one of us fearlessly goes out in the heat of day to look at a load of stones yeah there are drug addicts who might attack you yeah and one of us sits in the comfort and sloth of a large i mean you know absolutely clear
我们改去吃午饭了，我们吃了一个巨大的、巨大的挂在我们餐桌上方的烤肉串。也许如果你提醒我，我会发一张照片，那是一张巨大的食物的照片，真的很棒。好吧，我想关于……我想这个问题已经有了答案：我们中的一个人无所畏惧地在炎热的天气里出去看一堆石头——是的，那里有可能会袭击你的瘾君子——而我们中的另一个人则坐在舒适懒散的大……我是说，你知道，这绝对很清楚。
no no i was i was engaging with the local spartan citizenry um and uh you were gorging your face i have to say modern sparta modern sparta you know it's not the it wouldn't be the first place in anybody's list would it i'm not knocking it but it's it's it's a little bit humdrum it doesn't it's great if you like tractor factories yeah it doesn't be the first place in anybody's list, would it? I'm not knocking it, but it's a little bit humdrum. It's great if you like tractor factories. Yeah, it doesn't speak of the romance of the ancient world. But then neither did Sparta in antiquity, famously. So famously, Thucydides, the Athenian, who writes up the Peloponnesian War,
不，不，我是在与当地的斯巴达市民进行交流，而你则在大快朵颐。我必须说，现代的斯巴达，现代的斯巴达，你知道，它不会是任何人愿望清单上的第一名，对吧？我不是在贬低它，但它有点单调乏味。如果你喜欢拖拉机厂，那它可太棒了。不，它不会是任何人愿望清单上的第一名，对吧？我不是在贬低它，但它有点单调乏味。如果你喜欢拖拉机厂，那它可太棒了。是的，它并没有说明古代世界的浪漫。但话又说回来，古时的斯巴达也并非如此，这是出了名的。因此，著名的雅典人修昔底德，也就是伯罗奔尼撒半岛战争的记录者，
says of Sparta that he imagines that it's become deserted and that only the temples and the foundations of the buildings remain he said that he thinks that people would no longer you know people simply wouldn't believe that the place had been as powerful as it really was yeah i can because because because sparta you know basically it was an agglomeration of various villages. It famously didn't have a wall because it had its shield wall. Yeah. You know, it didn't invest in the kind of things that the Athenians invested in. Well, we had been there, you see.
对斯巴达的评价是，他想象它已经荒废了，只剩下寺庙和建筑物的地基。他说他认为人们再也不会，你知道，人们根本不会相信这个地方曾经像它实际上那样强大。是的，我可以，因为因为因为斯巴达，你知道，基本上它是由各种村庄聚集而成的。它闻名的一点是没有城墙，因为它有盾墙。是的。你知道，它没有投资雅典人所投资的那种东西。嗯，我们去过那里，你看。
We'd been there in Assassin's Creed Odyssey. My son and I. Okay, so how does it look in that? It looks great. It does look a bit Collection of Villages-ish. So there's no wall. These things are done. They were all done in collaboration with archaeologists and stuff. So I think it's reasonably, well, as accurate as it can be in a video game.
我们在《刺客信条：奥德赛》里去过那里。我和我儿子。好吧，那它在游戏里看起来怎么样？看起来很棒。它看起来确实有点“村庄集合体”的味道。所以没有城墙。这些都是完成的。它们都是在考古学家等的协助下完成的。所以我认为它相当合理，嗯，和电子游戏里能做到的尽量准确一样。
But it bears no relation to the tractor factories. So the reason I suggested the Temple of Artemis Orthia is because that was a very old building um and it was covered in very sinister masks so if you went to the museum you might have seen some of them um so there were kind of marked you know images of of young men but also images of hideous crones howling in pain wow very very sinister that's good and it was out in the marshes so it was surrounded by the croaking of frogs um and there was a very kind of antique statue of artemis who is the the virgin huntress the sister of apollo the the mistress of of wild animals and um that's where they played the cheese game yeah um this is where people compete for cheese right young people and they're the piles of their piles of cheese on a table,
但这与拖拉机厂毫无关系。所以我建议去阿尔忒密斯·俄耳提亚神庙的原因是，那是一座非常古老的建筑，嗯，而且它上面布满了非常阴森的面具。如果你去过博物馆，你可能已经见过其中的一些。所以那里有某种标记，你知道，年轻男子的形象，还有在痛苦中嚎叫的 hideous 老太婆的形象。哇，非常非常阴森。这很棒。它在沼泽里，所以周围都是青蛙的呱呱叫声。那里有一尊非常古色古香的阿尔忒密斯雕像，她是一位处女猎人，阿波罗的姐姐，野生动物的女主人，嗯……这就是他们玩奶酪游戏的地方。是的，呃，这就是人们争夺奶酪的地方，对吧？年轻人，桌子上有成堆的奶酪，
and there are men armed with whips. So this is a bit like something from the Cotswold Olympics that we talked about recently. It is very similar, yes, very similar. And you have to brave the whips to get the cheese. And basically it's a kind of coming-of-age ritual. So you'd success in the cheese game. Then means, as a young Spartan man, success in the cheese game, then means
还有手持皮鞭的男人们。所以这有点像我们最近谈论的科茨沃尔德奥林匹克运动会上的场景。非常相似，是的，非常相似。你必须冒着皮鞭的危险去拿奶酪。基本上，这是一种成年礼。所以如果在奶酪游戏中取得成功，那么作为一名年轻的斯巴达男子，如果在奶酪游戏中取得成功，那就意味着
as a young Spartan man, that you have the chance to join the Cryptea. We're going to come to that, Tom. Don't tell us what the Cryptea is. I'm not allowed to talk about that? No, you have to talk about it later. Have you worked out a structure for this program? I have. Because I have nothing to say, I have
作为一名年轻的斯巴达男子，你将有机会加入隐秘青年队（Cryptea）。我们要谈到那个，汤姆。别告诉我们什么是隐秘青年队。我不被允许谈论那个吗？不，你得稍后谈论。你为这个节目制定好结构了吗？是的。因为我无话可说，我
been able to devote my time. The hours that I spend preparing for the rest is history. I have put able to devote my time, the hours that I spend preparing for The Rest is History, I have put them into preparing a structure for you to interrogate you about the history of Sparta. So it's all about... And you've become Melvin Bragg. Yeah.
得以把时间投入其中。我花在为《历史的其余部分》做准备上的那些小时，我已经能够把时间投入其中，我花在为《历史的其余部分》做准备上的那些小时，我已经把它们投入到了为你准备一个结构中，以便盘问你关于斯巴达的历史。所以这一切都是关于……而你已经变成了梅尔文·布拉格（Melvin Bragg）。是的。
Well, I mean, I think people have seen that coming for a while, haven't they? That's terrifying. Yeah. We've got shouting at me. We've got similarly luxuriant hair as as as well known yes okay so i'll tell you what we should do because i've given this so much thought i think what we should do is for a couple of minutes you should give just a complete sort of very broad brush overview of sparta of sort of ancient sparta and then we'll get into
好吧，我的意思是，我想人们已经预料到这一点有一段时间了，不是吗？太可怕了。是的。我们在对着我喊叫。我们也有同样浓密的头发，正如众所周知的。是的。好吧，那我告诉你我们该怎么做，因为我对这件事深思熟虑过，我想我们应该做的就是，花几分钟时间，你来对斯巴达做一个非常宽泛的概述——对古代斯巴达的一个大致概述，然后我们再进入
these questions that i have so brilliantly put out. Before I do that, I know we don't usually talk about historiography, about how we know about things, but I think it's really, really important with Sparta. Before we get into the history of it and the weirdness of it, basically, I have to flag up
这些我如此出色地列出的问题。在此之前，我知道我们通常不谈论史学，不谈论我们是如何了解事物的，但我认为这对于斯巴达来说真的、真的很重要。在我们深入了解它的历史和它的诡异之处之前，基本上，我必须指出
that historians who write about it talk about the Spartan mir mirage right and they refer to it as a mirage in a way that they don't about other you know they don't talk about athens or rome like that and the reason is that um we have very few sources written by spartans yeah kieran right we have asked this question he says are we all are we just dealing with things that other people say about the spartans rather than the things they say about themselves? Basically, so we've got two poets, Teteus and Alckman from the 7th century. And then basically, aside from that, we have no Spartans.
那些撰写关于它的历史学家谈到了斯巴达的海市蜃楼，对吧？他们称之为海市蜃楼，这种方式是他们谈论其他地方时所没有的——你知道，他们不会那样谈论雅典或罗马。原因在于，嗯，我们拥有的由斯巴达人撰写的资料非常少。是的，基兰（Kieran）正确地提出了这个问题，他说，我们是不是都在处理其他人对斯巴达人的看法，而不是他们自己对自己的看法？基本上，所以我们有两位诗人，公元前7世纪的提尔泰乌斯（Tyrtæus）和阿尔克曼（Alcman）。然后基本上，除此之外，我们就没有斯巴达人了。
So there are multiple kind of layers of mystery. So there is what the Spartans actually did. There's what the Spartans kind of said they did or kind of claimed that they did there's what other greeks other contemporaries said the spartans did and then there's the kind of what people since have said the spartans did yeah so there's just kind of it's a constant echo chamber of of weird reports and rumors and the the problem is is that the origins of sparta and everything that makes it distinctive is rooted in a period of greek history called the archaic which is notoriously tricky to make sense of right and um iris murdoch the great novelist said of of archaic greece that
所以这里有多层神秘感。首先是斯巴达人实际做了什么；其次是斯巴达人声称他们做了什么，或者他们认为自己做了什么；然后是其他希腊人、其他同时代的人说斯巴达人做了什么；接着是后人说斯巴达人做了什么。所以，这只是一种由诡异的报道和谣言构成的永恒回音室。问题在于，斯巴达的起源以及使其与众不同的一切，都根植于希腊历史上的一个被称为“古风时期”（Archaic period）的时期，而这个时期以难以理清而闻名。没错。而且，伟大的小说家爱丽丝·默多克（Iris Murdoch）曾这样评价古风时期的希腊：
it's a game with with very few pieces where the skill of the player lies in complicating the rules. Right. And that is absolutely the case with Sparta. So I just need to flag that up. It's a bit like Duel Flunking, very similar to that. Well, yeah, it's actually not like Duel Flunking, because Duel Flunking, you can see footage of it. Yeah.
这是一个棋子极少的游戏，而玩家的技巧就在于把规则搞得极其复杂。没错。斯巴达的情况绝对就是这样。所以我只需要指出这一点。这有点像决斗恶作剧（Duel Flunking），和那个非常相似。嗯，是的，实际上它不像决斗恶作剧，因为决斗恶作剧，你可以看到视频素材。是的。
Whereas this, it's difficult to get a handle on so it's it's there's a lot of myth here okay but the myth in itself is very powerful and is important so i think that's so let's come back to that in a second but now just give us yeah okay an overview who are the spartans what's the story why do they end okay so uh sparta is it it's it's girt on both side by great mountain ranges it's got the sea to the south it's girt on both sides by great mountain ranges. It's got the sea to the south. It's got kind of dark hills to the north. So it's very naturally well fortified.
然而这个，很难让人捉摸，所以这里有很多神话。好吧，但神话本身非常有力量，也很重要。所以我想，让我们稍后再回到这一点上来，但现在，请给我们一个概述——好吧，斯巴达人是谁？故事是怎样的？为什么他们最终……好吧，斯巴达，它……它两边都被巨大的山脉环绕，南部濒海。它两边都被巨大的山脉环绕，南部濒海。它的北部有一些昏暗的山丘。所以它天然地防守严密。
So it's ideally suited basically to be a military power. In mythology, it's chiefly famous as the home of Helen, who marries Menelaus, the king of Sparta, at that generation after the Trojan War. It gets burnt. New people come. These are the people who claim to be the Spartans, supposedly. Sparta in the 8th, 7th centuries for Greeks is an absolute model of how not to run a city. It's terrible. The rich persecute the poor. Everyone's kind of given over to all kinds of depravity.
因此，它非常适合成为一个军事强国。在神话中，它最为著名的是海伦的故乡。在特洛伊战争之后的那一代人中，海伦嫁给了斯巴达国王墨涅拉俄斯。它被烧毁了。新的人来了。这些人据称就是自称为斯巴达人的人。在希腊人眼中，8世纪和7世纪的斯巴达简直是如何不治理城市的典范。太糟糕了。富人迫害穷人。每个人都沉溺于各种堕落之中。
They go to war with their neighbors over on the other side of Mount Tegatus, a place called Messenia, which is even a kind of richer agricultural land than Sparta is. The Spartans conquer it. This money then enhances the class differences. The whole city seems to be falling to pieces. They also need military manpower to keep the Mycenaeans down. And so they institute a radical redrafting of their constitution, which basically transforms it into a kind of slave state where all the Spartan citizens are conditioned and trained to fight as warriors and this makes them the most formidable fighting force in Greece.
他们与泰格托斯山另一侧的邻国交战，那个地方叫麦西尼亚（Messenia），那里的农业土地甚至比斯巴达还要富饶。斯巴达人征服了它。这笔财富随后加剧了阶级分化。整个城市似乎正在分崩离析。他们还需要军事人力来镇压麦西尼亚人。因此，他们对宪法进行了彻底的重新起草，基本上将其转变为一种奴隶制国家，所有的斯巴达公民都被塑造成并训练成作为战士去战斗，这使他们成为希腊最强大的战斗力量。
Sparta is the largest city, it's the most proficient military power in Greece. As such it is able basically to bring most of the Peloponnese under its rule. It plays a leading role in the Persian Wars, famous defence of Thermopylae. It wins the Battle of Plataea in 479, the year after Thermopylae, which sees the Persian invasion brought to an end. The rising power of Athens brings it to conflict with Sparta. Sparta ends up winning that. For a few years, its kind of mastery of Greece is undisputed, but Greece being Greece, they're endlessly fighting with another. The whole thing implodes. Thebes, a city that previously had been very, very marginal,
斯巴达是最大的城市，也是希腊最精锐的军事力量。因此，它基本上能够将大部分伯罗奔尼撒半岛置于其统治之下。它在波斯战争中发挥了领导作用，例如著名的温泉关防御战。它赢得了公元前479年的普拉提亚战役，也就是温泉关战役的次年，这场战役宣告了波斯入侵的结束。雅典日益强大，导致其与斯巴达发生冲突。斯巴达最终赢得了这场冲突。在几年时间里，它对希腊的统治地位毋庸置疑，但希腊毕竟是希腊，它们无休止地内讧。整个体制土崩瓦解。底比斯，一个此前一直非常、非常边缘化、
very much looked down upon, rises to this incredible military peak and destroys Sparta in two famous battles and from that point and and the the what the Thebans do is to divest the Spartans of Messenia which up till then had basically provided them with their great power stages and once Messenia has gone Sparta is immediately transformed into a kind of second-class power from that point on they they obdurately cling to their independence but they become more and more marginal and they end up absorbed into the roman empire and essentially they become a kind of um cosplay version of their ancestors yeah they you know they lay on kind of um spectacular whipping demonstrations for the entertainment of visiting tourists and that kind of thing. When the Roman Empire falls, Sparta gets caught up in
饱受鄙视的城市，崛起达到了令人难以置信的军事巅峰，并在两场著名的战役中摧毁了斯巴达。从那时起，底比斯人做的事就是剥夺斯巴达人对麦西尼亚的控制权，而在此之前，麦西尼亚基本上为他们提供了强大的权势地位。一旦麦西尼亚失去，斯巴达立刻从那时起沦为二流强国。他们顽固地坚守独立，但却越来越边缘化，最终被吞并进罗马帝国，本质上变成了他们祖先的“Cosplay”版本。是的，你知道，他们为了游览游客的娱乐而上演各种……壮观的鞭笞表演之类的东西。当罗马帝国灭亡时，斯巴达被卷入了
the process of barbarian invasions, it gets sacked. In the sixth century, Slavs invade, Sparta gets completely denuded, people take to the mountains and the hills and Mistres, the Byzantine city that you referred to, basically it's made of what remains of the urban fabric of Sparta. And no one lives in the Eurotas from that point up until the Greek War of Independence when Sparta is refounded in this kind of classicizing way that the Greeks have after they've won their independence. And the myth is much greater than the reality of downtown Sparta today. Yes.
蛮族入侵的进程中，遭到洗劫。在6世纪，斯拉夫人入侵，斯巴达彻底荒凉，人们逃往山峦丘陵。你提到的拜占庭城市米斯特拉斯，基本上就是由斯巴达残存的城市建筑废墟构成的。从那时起，直到希腊独立战争爆发、斯巴达以希腊人在赢得独立后所采用的那种古典主义方式重建之前，欧罗塔斯河谷再无人居住。神话远比今天市中心斯巴达的现实要宏大得多。是的。
But in a sense, that's always been the case. So how much... It's always been a vital complement to even at its absolute heyday, when people came up against Sparta, they were fighting the myth as well as the reality. OK, let's get back to Kieran Roach's question then. So everything we're going to be talking about in the rest of this podcast, how much is it, do you think, as far as anyone can say about ancient history, how much is it based on genuine historical evidence
但在某种程度上，情况一直如此。那么，有多少……即使在其全盛时期，当人们对抗斯巴达时，他们对抗的既有现实，也有神话，这始终是一个至关重要的补充。好吧，让我们回到基兰·罗奇（Kieran Roach）的问题。因此，我们在接下来的播客中要谈论的一切，在多大程度上——就任何人对古代历史的断言而言——它是基于真正的历史证据，
and how much is it a projection, as Kieran says, of other people's prejudices and other people's kind of wish fulfillment in a way about the spartans the since academic studies of sparta are are really tough because it's all about fragments of pottery fragments of source material um the sifting and the balancing of texts that might often be written kind of centuries apart. So it is a challenge. And it's undoubtedly the case that an awful lot of what we know about Sparta, people who were consciously mythologizing it, whether because they admired it, which lots of people did, or whether because they admired it which lots of people did or whether because they hated it which equally lots of people did so it's i think it's very difficult but i think that um i think it's entirely justified to kind of construct a kind of sense of of what the society
又有多少像基兰所说的那样，是其他人偏见的投射，以及其他人对斯巴达人某种形式的愿望实现？自以来，对斯巴达的学术研究真的非常艰难，因为这完全取决于陶器碎片、源材料碎片，以及对可能相隔几个世纪撰写的文本的筛选和权衡。所以这是一个挑战。毫无疑问，我们对斯巴达的了解中，有相当大一部分来自于那些有意识地将其神话化的人——无论是出于钦佩（很多人都这样做），
had been like because it's been so influential it was massively influential on on the greeks back in antiquity and it's been hugely influential in the modern period as well so i i think i think you can kind of you know you know this isn't a this isn't a kind of a lecture for a degree course yeah it's not the open university we don't want to go down that road no it's not um and we're not even melvin bragg i mean no matter what some people may have said earlier in the podcast where we as you said to me when we first discussed doing the podcast it's all about the b. As you said to me when we first discussed it in the podcast, it's all about the bants. It's all about the bants, yeah.
还是出于厌恶（同样有很多人这样做）。所以我认为这非常困难，但我认为，呃，我认为构建一种关于这个社会曾经是怎样的“感觉”是完全合理的，因为它太有影响力了。它对古代的希腊人产生了巨大影响，在现代时期也产生了巨大影响。所以，呃，我认为你可以……你知道，这不是一个学位课程的讲座。是的，这不是开放大学，我们不想走那条路。不，不是的，
When my wife heard those words, she said, don't do it, for God's sake, don't do it. Right, anyway, let's move on. So why is Sparta Sparta, Tom? Is it about geography? Why has it become this military machine? Or is it less different from other Greek city-states than we commonly think I think it's really different okay I mean to begin
我们甚至不是梅尔文·布拉格，不管播客早期某些人怎么说。正如你我们在第一次讨论做这个播客时对我说的那样，一切都在于插科打诨（bants）。一切都在于插科打诨，是的。当我的太太听到这些话时，她说：“千万别做，看在上帝的份上，别做。”好吧，无论如何，让我们继续。那么，汤姆，为什么斯巴达是斯巴达？是因为地理原因吗？为什么它会变成这个军事机器？还是说它其实不像我们通常认为的那样，与其他希腊城邦有那么大不同？我认为它非常不同。好吧。我的意思是，一开始
with it isn't different so back in the Bronze Age so a further confusion is it has two names actually has loads of names so it's also called lack of diamond yeah and like it's that's what it's originally called we know that because um tablets have been found in actually in in boeotia and thebes that names it it's in it's mentioned in homer it's it's hollow lacedaemon um sparta seems to mean um land that's sown so sparrow is is i so so it seems to so basically lacedaemon is the old name. Sparta comes to mean this fertile valley where people are plowing and sowing. And I think that that's the key to Sparta's initial status,
它并没有什么不同。所以早在青铜器时代——另一个混淆点是它有两个名字，实际上有好多名字——它也被称为拉凯代梦（Lacedaemon），最初就是这么叫的。我们知道这一点，因为在维奥蒂亚和底比斯实际上发现了刻有这个名字的泥板。荷马史诗中也提到了它，那是“空旷的拉凯代梦”。斯巴达似乎意味着“播种的土地”，因为 sparo 是……所以，基本上拉凯代梦是旧称。斯巴达后来成了这个肥沃山谷的名字，人们在那里耕作播种。我认为这正是斯巴达最初地位的关键所在，
is that it has this fertile valley and it is very well defended. And the thing that makes Sparta aberrant is that they conquer their neighbours. Right. And they reduce them to a level of servitude that other Greeks regarded as shocking. And this servitude is called helotage. They're called helots. We'll come to the helots in a sec. But why does the military culture develop?
那就是它拥有这个肥沃的山谷，而且防御非常严密。使斯巴达变得异常的是，他们征服了邻居。没错。并将他们降为其他希腊人视为令人震惊的奴役水平。这种奴役被称为“黑劳士制度”（helotage）。他们被称为“黑劳士”（helots）。我们一会儿就会谈到黑劳士。但是为什么军事文化会发展起来？
That's a question we've had tons of people asking that. Ben Gladwin, for example, says, why does Sparta develop this unique military culture when there are so many different greek city states why are they the outlier well as ever with greek history there's there's a myth and then there's a probable reality so the myth is that um in the wake of the conquest of messenia, as I said, Sparta falls to pieces. It becomes a model of bad order. And an eminent Spartan by the name of Lycurgus, which means wolf worker, goes to Delphi and consults with the Oracle.
这是一个我们收到无数人提问的问题。例如，本·格拉德温（Ben Gladwin）问：为什么在有这么多不同的希腊城邦的情况下，斯巴达会发展出这种独特的军事文化？为什么他们是特例？好吧，跟希腊历史一如既往的那样，其中有一个神话，然后还有一个可能的现实。所以神话是，呃，在征服麦西尼亚之后，正如我所说，斯巴达分崩离析了。它成了秩序败坏的典范。一个名叫吕库戈斯（Lycurgus，意思是“狼工匠”）的杰出斯巴达人前往德尔斐咨询神谕。
And Apollo sees him and says, oh, I don't know who you are. I'm not sure who you are. Lycurgus, are you a god or a man? man i'm not sure but i think you're probably a god so that's kind of you know this strange ambivalent heroic status that lycurgus has and the oracle gives lycurgus a constitution which basically provides um it transforms the citizens of Sparta into a military elite. Yeah. And they can do this because they've conquered Messina. And so they can use the Messinians as basically to grow the food.
阿波罗看到他并说：“哦，我不知道你是谁。我不确定你是谁。吕库戈斯，你是神还是人？人。我不太确定，但我猜你大概是个神。”所以这就是那种，你知道的，吕库戈斯所拥有的这种奇怪的、矛盾的英雄地位。神谕赋予了吕库戈斯一部宪法，基本上提供了一个……它将斯巴达公民转变为一个军事精英。是的。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们征服了麦西尼亚。因此他们可以利用麦西尼亚人来种植粮食。
Slaves, basically. So Piteas, the poet, says that they're like donkeys laden down with heavy burdens. The Spartans also have people called perioikoi which are people who live around sparta who can do the the things like um make the pots or make the armor or whatever the spartan warriors themselves that's all they do okay so any any other any other greek city the people who fight they do it on a strictly amateur basis they're carpenters they're um whatever but in sparta that's not the case they are purely soldiers so young tom holland is born in the year 450 or whatever how does his life work in sparta so talk me through it well young tom holland is born and he's a bit he looks a bit wussy so he'd probably he'd be taken to uh these magistrates called EFORs who are elected every year.
基本上就是奴隶。所以诗人皮铁阿斯（Pytheas）说他们就像负重累累的毛驴。斯巴达人还有被称为“庇里阿科伊”（perioikoi）的人，也就是住在斯巴达周边的人，他们可以做诸如制作陶器或制造盔甲之类的事情，而斯巴达战士自己，他们只做这些。好吧，所以任何……任何其他希腊城邦，那些参战的人都严格以业余身份进行，他们是木匠，是……诸如此类。但在斯巴达，情况并非如此，他们纯粹是士兵。所以年轻的汤姆·霍兰生于公元前450年左右，他在斯巴达的生活是如何运作的？跟我讲讲。好吧，年轻的汤姆·霍兰出生了，他看起来有点软弱，所以他可能会被带到……
The EFORs would inspect me. They would say, is he going to go up to be a mighty muscle-bound warrior? I feel so sorry for you. I know. And so I'd be taken to a place called the Apothetai, which is the dumping ground, which is a ravine at the foot of Mount Togatus. And I'd be exposed there along with all the other baby boys. All the other misfits.
这些每年选出的被称为“埃福尔”（Ephors，监察官）的官员面前。监察官会检查我。他们会说：“他能成长为一名强大的肌肉发达的战士吗？”我太同情你了。我知道。所以我会被带到一个叫“阿波特泰”（Apothetai，意思是“弃婴场”）的地方，那是泰格托斯山脚下的一个峡谷。我会被和其他所有男婴一起遗弃在那里。所有不合格的怪胎。
Don't pass muster. But let's say it's young Dominic Sandbrook. Wow, very different story. A fine, strapping young lad. Yeah. Clearly made to grow up and defend his city. Then at the age of seven seven you'd go to the equivalent of a boarding school right you'd go to a kind of a barracks um and you'd undergo what's
没有达到标准。但假设是年轻的杜威·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。哇，完全不同的故事。一个身强力壮的小伙子。是的。显然是天生为了长大后保卫城市。然后在七岁时，七岁时你就会去寄宿学校的同类地方，对吧？你就会去一种军营，并且你要经历所谓的
called the ago gay um which is uh um it's a kind of train training procedure and you'd be under um people i mean basically that that your instructor would would in greek means a kind of a child a herd so you're being raised like animals and it's that thing with like you know the the maker of wolves you're being you're you're simultaneously being trained to be ferocious like a wolf but also to be broken to control and discipline so this is not grey fries in the billy bunter this is not no no it's not and so you are you are schooled in um in in the use of arms you're schooled in drill you're schooled in um wrestling you're schooled to forage so there'll be times where you you were not fed enough so is this the cheese go out is this the no that's it that's it that's different because that's a game this is you know you have to go out into the onto
“阿哥盖”（agoge），这是一种……一种训练程序。你将归……我的意思是，基本上你的教官在希腊语中意味着某种儿童牧人，所以你像动物一样被抚养长大。就是那种……你知道的，“狼的制造者”，你一方面被训练得像狼一样凶猛，另一方面又被驯服以接受控制和纪律。所以这不是《比利·邦特》里的格雷弗莱尔斯公学，这不是，不，这不是。所以你要接受武器使用的学校教育，接受操练的学校教育，接受摔跤的学校教育，接受野外觅食的学校教育。所以会有这样的时候，你没有得到足够的喂养，所以这是奶酪游戏吗？出去……是不是……不，那是……那是另一回事，因为那是个游戏。这是（你必须）去到
the mountainside and kind of kill animals or you have to steal things from other people or whatever so there's a famous story of the um a boy who is found um and he's got a fox which he's going to eat and he hides it under his tunic and an elder stops him and asks him what he's doing and he says absolutely nothing meanwhile the fox is gnawing away at his stomach and the boy suddenly drops down dead and he hasn't mentioned it oh my god do that you know i mean this this story is clearly not true because who would eat a fox but it suggests that boys you know young boys are taking on um vulpine characteristics they're trained to become foxes. And also that stoicism is absolutely key to the Spartan sense of themselves.
山腰上杀死动物，或者你必须从其他人那里偷东西之类的。所以有一个著名的故事，讲的是……一个男孩被发现了，他身上藏着一只他准备吃掉的狐狸，他把它藏在长袍下面，一个长老拦住他，问他在做什么，他说“什么都没做”。与此同时，狐狸正在啃他的肚子，男孩突然倒地身亡，而他却一直没提这事。天哪！你知道，我的意思是，这个故事显然不是真的，因为谁会吃狐狸呢？但它表明，男孩们……年轻的男孩们正在展现出……狐狸般的特征，他们被训练成狐狸。而且这种斯多葛主义（stoicism）对于斯巴达人的自我认知是绝对关键的。
Yes. It's resilience. So the reed Sparta and the area around it is called Laconia. And we still have the word laconic. You're beaten if you talk too much. You're encouraged to say things as concisely as you possibly can. Just like you on this podcast right i mean exactly like me yes and the thing that's the thing that's also very distinctive about sparta is it's
是的。这就是坚韧。所以，斯巴达及其周边地区被称为拉科尼亚。我们至今仍在使用“拉科尼亚式的”（laconic，简洁的）这个词。如果你废话太多，你就会挨打。你被鼓励尽可能简洁地表达事情。就像你在播客里一样，对吧？我的意思是，完全就像我，是的。而且斯巴达还有一个非常独特的特征，那就是
not just boys who get an education girls do as well yes so we had tons of girls girls and women so so girls also um you know they're they seem to be have been taught to read to write um they're taught to be kind of forthright um to express their opinions they um they they they have this kind of distinctive dance where they slap their buttocks with the bottom of their feet with the bottom of their feet yeah so you kind of you know sort of leap up yeah you leap up you kick your legs up and you hit your buttocks with the bottom of your feet okay OK, so no one was doing that when I was in Sparta, disappointing. Something they could revive. Yeah.
不仅男孩能接受教育，女孩也可以。是的，所以我们有大量的女孩，女孩和妇女。所以女孩们也……你知道，她们似乎被教导阅读、写作，她们被教导要直言不讳，要表达自己的意见。她们……她们……她们有一种独特的舞蹈，用脚后跟拍打自己的臀部。用脚后跟拍打臀部，是的。所以你某种程度上，你知道，跳起来，是的，你跳起来，把腿踢高，用脚后跟拍打臀部。好吧，好吧，所以我去斯巴达时没有人做那个，真让人失望。这是他们可以复兴的东西。是的。
They they're known as they wear these kind of very skimpy slits tunics that causes a lot of kind of prurient disapproval from from other Greeks. Sometimes they wrestle naked um and one of the things that girls do is i mean it's so it's kind of every school boy's worst nightmare is it that you at certain points you you you have to strip naked and stand before the girls and the girl you know if you don't measure up the girls are encouraged to laugh and mock you really so yeah so that's fun yeah um and then i mean it's good for the soul so at a certain point you you will play the cheese game that we talked about and then the odd thing is so that that the ideal is simultaneously to um to kind of encourage this egalitarianism but it doesn't mean everyone's
她们被称为……她们穿着这种非常暴露开叉的长袍，这引起了其他希腊人大量的淫邪非议。有时她们会赤裸摔跤。女孩们要做的事情之一就是——我的意思是，这简直是每个男校学生的噩梦——在某些时刻，你必须脱光衣服，站在女孩们面前，如果你不够标准，女孩们会被鼓励嘲笑和嘲弄你，真的。所以，是的，这很有趣。是的，而且，我的意思是，这对灵魂有好处。所以在某个时刻，你将玩我们讨论过的奶酪游戏。然后奇怪的事情是，这个理想一方面是为了鼓励这种平均主义，但这并不意味着每个人都是
equal yeah so there's this ferocious sense of competition you have to make yourself the best and if you win the cheese game or if you pass kind of various tests then that your huge opportunity is that you you can join the cryptia this kind of elite. Yes. Which is basically Duke of Edinburgh Award, the gold, whatever it is. Gold Award. Yeah, Gold Award. And you go up into the mountains. You go down the other side. You go into Messenia and you have to kill a helot.
平等的，是的。所以这里有一种残酷的竞争感。你必须让自己成为最好的。如果你赢了奶酪游戏，或者如果你通过了各种测试，那么你巨大的机会就是你可以加入隐秘青年队（Cryptia），这个精英组织。是的。基本上这就是爱丁堡公爵奖的金奖，无论它是什么。金奖。是的，金奖。然后你上山去。你从另一边下去。你进入麦西尼亚，你必须杀死一个黑劳士。
So helot is a slave. These are the people who are tilling the land. These are the Messenians. And if you do that, then you. So a helot is a slave. These are the people who are tilling the land. These are the Mycenaeans. And if you do that, then you come back and you get your gold award. And you have the chance to enter what's called the Hippaeus, which is basically the cavalry, the knights. But this being Sparta, they're not. They're all on foot.
所以黑劳士是一个奴隶。这些人是耕种土地的人。这些是麦西尼亚人。如果你这样做了，那么你……所以黑劳士是一个奴隶。这些人是耕种土地的人。这些是麦西尼亚人。如果你这样做了，那么你回来就能拿到你的金奖。你就有机会进入被称为“伊佩伊斯”（Hippaeus）的组织，也就是骑兵，骑士。但既然这里是斯巴达，他们其实不是骑兵。他们全都是步兵。
But these are the 300 who go with Lenny, Dust of Thermopylae, the famous 300, as in the in the film talk to me about the killing the slave you can kill any slave you can just leap on them and stab them in the neck or whatever so so helots are again very just a very distinctive kind of phenomenon in sparta so you know people kind of discuss what were hell it's basically helots were helots they were that they were distinctive there was a there was a village in in laconia called helos and so there were all kinds of stories that these were the first helots other stories were that um the first helots were spartans who'd been cowards and had been reduced to this servitude to humiliate them but basically um helots are there to work the land and to provide the messes that enable the spartan warriors to function as warriors and so it's it's a kind of chicken and
但这些就是随列昂尼达斯前往温泉关的300勇士，也就是电影里的那著名的300人。跟我讲讲杀死奴隶的事。你可以杀死任何奴隶？你可以直接扑上去，刺他们的脖子之类的？所以黑劳士同样也是斯巴达一种非常独特的现象。所以你知道，人们会讨论黑劳士究竟是什么。基本上黑劳士就是黑劳士。他们是独特的。拉科尼亚有一个村庄叫海洛斯（Helos），所以有各种各样的传说，说这些是最初的黑劳士；还有其他的传说称，最初的黑劳士是那些表现懦弱并被降为这种奴役以羞辱他们的斯巴达人。但基本上，黑劳士的存在是为了耕种土地，并提供使斯巴达战士能够作为战士运作的食堂。所以这是一个先有鸡还是先有蛋的情况：到底是斯巴达的军国主义让他们得以压制黑劳士，还是他们必须压制黑劳士，否则黑劳士就会起义杀死他们？我们有一个关于这个的问题。我们有很多问题。本吉（Benji）问：为什么黑劳士不反抗？斯巴达人对此感到害怕吗？保罗·霍加特（Paul Hogarth）问：斯巴达人对黑劳士起义的偏执程度有多高？这能解释他们的军国主义吗？那么，历史上曾有过黑劳士起义吗？好吧，斯巴达人对此非常偏执。
egg situation what comes first is it the militarism of sparta that enables them to keep the helots down or do they have to keep the helots down because otherwise the helots will rise up and kill them? We had a question about this. We had lots of questions. Benji, why didn't the helots revolt? And were the Spartans afraid of it? And Paul Hogarth says, how paranoid were the Spartans of a helot uprising? And does that explain their militarism? So was there ever a helot uprising? Well, the Spartans are very paranoid about it.
我的意思是，我认为很多……你知道的，对于一个自由公民来说，被鞭打或殴打——正如斯巴达人那样——你知道。而且我认为，悬在他们头顶的是一种提醒，提醒他们如果黑劳士获得权力和征服他们，他们将会遭遇什么。斯巴达人每年，监察官（Ephors）都会向麦西尼亚人宣战，他们认为这相当于为谋杀黑劳士发放许可。所以希罗多德有一句非常令人不寒而栗的话，他说，呃，唯有斯巴达人不把谋杀视为犯罪，
I mean, I think a lot of the, you know, for a free citizen to be whipped or to be beaten as Spartans were, you know And I think kind of hanging over it is a reminder of what will happen to them if the helots gain power and conquer them. The Spartans, every year, the Ephors declare war against the Messenians, which they see as licensing the murder of helots. So Herodotus has this kind of very chilling phrase where he says uh that the the spartans alone do not regard murder as a crime um and they are they practice a kind of very self-conscious eugenic so just as they um you know
并且他们实行一种非常自觉的优生学。就像他们……你知道，他们培育自己一样，他们以培育马匹、培育狗和培育自己而闻名。所以这就是为什么他们抛弃那些……你知道的，不达标的婴儿。相反，隐秘青年队员在通过他们的爱丁堡公爵奖时，会被分配杀害的对象。他们被分配杀害黑劳士。而这些黑劳士恰恰是那些表现出主动性、更聪明、更机智的人。所以他们试图培育出一代顺从的、奴性的人口。因此，他们实际上挑选出了最聪明、最有才华的黑劳士、麦西尼亚人，
they they breed themselves they're famous as breeding horses, for breeding dogs and for breeding themselves. So this is why they chuck out people who, you know, babies that don't measure up. So conversely, the members of the Cryptaea, when they're passing their Duke of Edinburgh, they're given people to kill. They're given helots to kill. And these helots are the ones who've shown initiative, who are smarter or clever or whatever. So they're trying to breed an adultish, servile population. So they've actually singled out the brightest, most talented helots, Messinians,
然后他们基本上对自己的孩子——我想是青少年——说：“去杀了他们。”是的。是的。而那随后就成为了……标志着，你知道的，你已经过关了。是的。他们还会做的一件事是，为了娱乐，有时当他们在食堂时，他们会带进来一个黑劳士。
and they basically say to their own children, teenagers, I guess, go and kill them. Yeah. Yeah. And that's then the their own children, teenagers, I guess, go and kill them. Yeah. Yeah. And that's then the mark of, you know, that you've kind of passed the grade. Yeah. And what they also do is for entertainment, sometimes when they're in their messes, they will bring a helot in.
黑劳士被迫穿上这些令人作呕的狗皮。你知道，这是为了让他们看起来荒谬、丑陋、满身疥疮。他们会给黑劳士灌下不掺水的纯酒——所以希腊人通常把酒和水混合，但他们给黑劳士喝纯的。黑劳士喝得酩酊大醉，神志不清，在一片醉酒的昏迷中瘫倒。斯巴达人随后会用动物骨头砸他，以此来结束这个夜晚。这一切的设计既是为了让黑劳士对酒精上瘾，从而使他们虚弱无力，也是为了给斯巴达人上一堂道德课，教育他们在任何事情上都要实行节制。
And the helots are made to wear these kind of revolting dog skins. You know, it's designed to make them look ridiculous and ugly and scabby and they will get the helots drunk on unmixed wine so the greeks mix wine yeah with water they give it they give it neat and the helot gets absolutely off his face uh he kind of collapses in a drunken stupor. The Spartans then kind of ran the evening off by pelting him with animal bones. And the whole thing is designed both to, you know, addict helots to drink. Yeah. So that they're enfeebled, but also to serve as a moral lesson to the Spartans to practice moderation in everything.
你可以看到这种做法对纳粹在东欧统治构想的影响。我的意思是，这完全是按照这个模式塑造的。纳粹将军们实际上谈到了斯巴达人和黑劳士。我的意思是，这有某种文本证据。所以他们的计划基本上是将波兰降为黑劳士制度。是的，完全如此。你问到了起义。你问到了起义。
And you can see the influence of this on, say, the way that the Nazis envisage their rule in Eastern Europe. I mean, it's absolutely modelled on this. But Nazi generals actually talk of the Spartans and the helots. I mean, there's sort of textual evidence for this. So their plan is basically to kind of reduce Poland to helotage. Yeah, exactly. And you asked about revolts. You asked about revolts.
所以在公元前465年，发生了一场特别毁灭性的地震。在此背景下，爆发了一场大规模的黑劳士起义。斯巴达人非常残酷地镇压了它。实际上，我的意思是，他们之后对黑劳士的对待似乎变得更加残酷。所以，再次地，他们向愿意帮助他们的黑劳士提供奖赏，
So in 465, there's a particularly devastating earthquake. And off the back of that, there's a massive helot revolt. And the Spartans repress it very brutally. And actually, I mean, their treatment of the helots after that seems to become even more brutal. So, again, they offer prizes to helots who will help them um and so about 2 000 helots step forward um and they show great initiative in in helping the spartans the spartans then kind of disappear them god because yeah these are people who are obvious leaders that's incredible and nobody even knows what their fate
于是大约有2000名黑劳士站了出来，他们在帮助斯巴达人方面表现出了极大的主动性。斯巴达人随后将他们“人间蒸发”了。天哪！因为，是的，这些人都是显而易见的领袖。这太令人难以置信了，而且没有人知道他们的命运如何。我的意思是，他们字面意义上彻底消失了。汤姆，把这与其他奴隶制度（比如美国南方等等）做比较，以及对混血的恐惧、对奴隶的恐惧以及某种种族主义进行比较，是不是完全疯了？这里有任何那样的元素吗？没有，没有，因为对希腊人来说，令人震惊的是黑劳士是希腊人。而且不仅如此，他们是多利亚人（Dorians）。所以这也是斯巴达人如何看待自己的一部分重要内容：他们认为自己是被称为多利亚人的入侵者，这些入侵者向南横扫，用这些伟大的亚该亚城市（迈锡尼、阿科斯，当然还有斯巴达）征服了伯罗奔尼撒半岛。而麦西尼亚人是多利亚人，就像斯巴达人一样。
is i mean they they literally vanish and is it completely demented tom to make a comparison with other slave systems so for example the american south let's say um and the sort of fear of miscegenation and the fear of the slaves and the sort of the racism is is there any element of that no no because because what's shocking for to the greeks is that the helots are greek so and actually more than that they they're dorian so this is also a important part of how the spartans see themselves is that they see themselves as these invaders called dorians who have have swept southwards and conquered the Peloponnese with these kind of great Achaean cities, Mycenae and Argos and of course Sparta. And the Mycenaeans are Dorians, like the Spartans.
所以从这个意义上说，他们是同胞。因此，实际上强加给他们的屈辱、决心将他们培育为奴隶阶层的这种意志，并不是因为他们被视为异类，也不是因为种族主义。恰恰相反。这是因为这里存在着一种不可思议的亲缘感。但是汤姆，既然如此，有一个显而易见的问题：是什么让一个斯巴达人成为斯巴达人？那么，如果他们和其他多利亚人、麦西尼亚人有着某种程度的亲缘关系，斯巴达人又是如何成为斯巴达人的呢？仅仅是因为特定的家族吗？还是字面意义上因为住在斯巴达这个事实？
So in that sense, they're kin. And so actually the humiliations that are imposed on them, the determination to breed them into a kind of slave people, isn't because they are seen as alien, isn't because of racism. It's absolutely the opposite. It's because there is this incredible sense of kinship. But Tom, in that case, here's an obvious question. What makes a Spartan a Spartan? So how do you become a Spartan if they're kind of vaguely related to the other Dorian peoples, to the Mycenaeans, how are the Spartans Spartans? Is it just particular families? Is it literally the fact of residency in Sparta?
从这个意义上说，他们是同类。因此，强加给他们的羞辱，那种决心将他们培育成奴隶阶层的做法，并不是因为他们被视为异类，也不是因为种族主义。恰恰相反。这是因为有一种强烈的同宗共祖之感。但是汤姆，既然如此，这里有一个显而易见的问题。是什么让斯巴达人成为斯巴达人？那么，如果他们与其他的多利安人、迈锡尼人有着某种模糊的血缘关系，你怎么能成为一个斯巴达人呢？斯巴达人究竟凭什么成为斯巴达人？难道只是特定的家族吗？还是字面意义上的居住在斯巴达的事实？
What is it that makes you Spartan? You have to be the son of freeborn Spartan parents. Yeah. And you have to have a certain kind of land qualification. Okay. And this is seen as the kind of the radical innovation of the lycurgian revolution right um and it's why sparta has appealed to the left as well as to the right is that um these incredible social differences which had seen the rich oppressing the poor
究竟是什么塑造了斯巴达人？你必须是土生土长的斯巴达父母的儿子。是的。而且你必须具备某种土地资格。好吧。这被视为吕库古革命的一种激进创新，对吧？呃，这也是为什么斯巴达既吸引左翼又吸引右翼的原因——呃，这些曾经富人压迫穷人的巨大社会差异
kind of get dissolved and everybody has to live the same life they all have to belong to a barracks they all have to eat the same food they all have to dress in the life. They all have to belong to a barracks. They all have to eat the same food. They all have to dress in the same way. They all have to fight in the same battle line. And the reality is, of course, that there are still people who are considerably richer than other people. But there has to be a certain property qualification. of this over time is that um you know spartan warriors die um there is a kind of uh you know as is always the way um the rich do tend to kind of increasingly monopolize land and so there's a steady kind of collapse in the number of people who are qualified to serve as spartans and that's one of the reasons that that leads to the collapse of Spartan power. Right. Okay. Fair enough.
在某种程度上被消解了，每个人都必须过同样的生活，都必须属于一个兵营，都必须吃同样的食物，都必须以同样的方式着装，都必须在同一个战线上战斗。当然，现实情况是，仍然有些人比其他人要富裕得多。但必须具备一定的财产资格。随着时间的推移，这种情况导致了——呃，你知道的，斯巴达战士会死去——有这样一种现象——正如历来如此的那样——富人确实往往会越来越多地垄断土地，因此，有资格担任斯巴达人的人数出现了持续的崩塌，这也是导致斯巴达力量崩溃的原因之一。没错。好吧。很有道理。
So this, again, goes right the way back to the beginnings, is that most of the Spartans are Dorian, as I said, but there are families that aren't. And two of these families provide the two kings that rule at any one time. Oh, yes. So Sparta is a kind of weird mix. So you've got the ethos, the elected magistrates. You've got the assembly, which is kind of public assembly.
所以这同样可以追溯到最早的起源，大多数斯巴达人是多利安人，正如我所说，但也有一些家庭不是。而其中两个家庭提供了在任何特定时期统治的两位国王。哦，是的。所以斯巴达是一种奇怪的混合体。所以你有精神风貌，有选举产生的行政长官。你有公民大会，这是一种公众集会。
You've got the equivalent of a senate. Gerasia is literally the Greek for senate. It's assembly of old men, which, which again has kind of consultative power. And then you have two kings. And both of these kings are descended ultimately, they say, from Heracles, the great kind of paradigmatic Greek hero, who's an Achaean.
你拥有相当于参议院的机构。Gerasia在希腊语中字面意思就是参议院。它是老年人议会，同样也拥有某种协商权力。然后你有两位国王。这两位国王最终都据说是赫拉克勒斯的后代，赫拉克勒斯是伟大的希腊典型英雄，而他是一个亚该亚人。
So weirdly, the kings in Sparta are not Dorian. They're Achaean. That that is strange it's kind of linked with the vanished past i suppose yes and um it basically it it it means that you know we were talking about the olympics yeah um and how olympian here you know winners in the olympics provide the greeks with a reminder of the heroic age, the age of heroes, and how heroes don't necessarily have the meaning that they have for us. Heroes are often very sinister figures, dangerous figures, who are kind of midway between humans and the gods. And the Spartans kings have that role. And so there's all kinds of myths about why there are two
所以奇怪的是，斯巴达的国王不是多利安人。他们是亚该亚人。这确实很奇怪，它某种程度上与消逝的过去有关，我想是的。是的，呃，基本上它意味着——你知道的，我们之前在谈论奥运会，是的——以及奥运会上的优胜者如何为希腊人提供对英雄时代、英雄时代的提醒，以及英雄对我们来说并不一定具有现在的意义。英雄往往是非常阴险的人物、危险的人物，他们介于人类和神明之间。斯巴达国王就扮演着这样的角色。因此，关于为什么会有两个
kings. The most popular myth is um there is uh that there's a spartan king he has um twins the spartans don't he dies the spartans don't know who should succeed so they go to delphi delphi says they should both rule but um the one who's eldest should uh should should be senior which is kind of classically unhelpful yeah kind of delving solution you know gives the solution with one hand and takes it away with the other so the spartans say fine okay so we'll have these two kings um but how are we going to find out um who the elder one is and so a messenian interestingly helot suggests well watch the queen and see which one of them she bathes first on the assumption that the elder son is going to
国王，流传着各种各样的神话。最受欢迎的神话是——呃，有一个斯巴达国王，他有——呃，有一对双胞胎，斯巴达人——他去世了，斯巴达人不知道谁应该继承，所以他们去德尔斐求签，德尔斐说他们两个都应该统治，但是——年纪最大的那个应该——应该——应该是资深的，这真是一个经典且毫无帮助的建议。是的，这是一种德尔斐式的解决方案，你知道的，一手给出了解决方案，另一手又把它拿走了。所以斯巴达人说，好吧，没问题——那我们就让这两个国王同时统治——但是我们要怎么找出——谁是年长的那一个呢？于是，有趣的是，一个美西尼亚的黑劳士建议说：盯着王后看，看她先给他们中的哪一个洗澡，理由是年长的儿子会是
be the favourite. And so they watch the queen, and she's not actually a queen. Sparta doesn't have queens, but the wife of the king. And they see which one it is, and that then becomes the founder of the senior branch of kings, and the other one is the junior branch. And that goes right the way through to, I think, the third century, this diarchy it's called.'s a very strange system okay one last
那个更受宠爱的。于是他们盯着王后看，其实她也不是王后，斯巴达没有王后，而是国王的妻子。他们看看到底是哪一个，然后这就成为了资深国王分支的创立者，而另一个则是初级分支。这种情况一直持续到，我想是公元三世纪，这种双王体制被称为非常奇怪的体制。好吧，在进入中场休息前，还有一个
quick very quick question before we go to the break Optopian asks a question that I don't really understand he says thoughts and if possible a tasting on the role played by the Spartans black soup I don't know what this is what is the black soup Tom so the black soup is this notoriously revolting dish. So a Spartan would bring the raw ingredients, the helicooks would brew it up. It was basically a kind of blood broth. And Spartans would wolf it down. Any visitors would say it was disgusting. And the joke was, you know, an Athenian tasted it and said, now I understand why the Spartans have no fear of death. Very good. All right, I'm off to have a bowl of soup.
非常迅速的问题。奥托皮安（Optopian）问了一个我其实不太理解的问题，他说：“如果有的话，对于斯巴达黑汤扮演的角色，能否发表一些看法并进行品评？”我不知道这是什么，黑汤到底是什么，汤姆？所以黑汤是一道出了名的令人作呕的菜肴。斯巴达人会带上生食材，由黑劳士厨师把它煮好。它基本上是一种血汤。斯巴达人会狼吞虎咽地吃下去。任何访客都会说它恶心极了。有个笑话是这样的，一个雅典人尝了之后说：“现在我明白为什么斯巴达人对死亡毫无畏惧了。”非常好。好了，我去喝碗汤了。
After the break, we shall go through some highlights of Spartan history and some of the characters, and then we'll talk about Sparta's reputation, and no doubt we'll be talking about 300. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about Sparta. We're going to be coming to 300, of course, later in the show.
休息过后，我们将回顾斯巴达历史的一些亮点以及其中的一些人物，然后我们将讨论斯巴达的名声，毫无疑问我们也会谈到《300勇士》。一会见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐而已》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史而已》（The Rest Is History）。我们正在聊斯巴达。当然，在节目的后面部分，我们将谈到《300勇士》。
But first of all, I want to talk about, we had so many questions, Tom. Let's just go through the questions. And a couple of them are about individuals. And one of the first individuals is Cleomenes so jonathan metzer says can you tell us about king cleomenes expansionist tried to suppress athenian democratic revolution exiled recalled insane imprisoned and then found dead from wounds in custody what's the story with him so i don't know anything about this do you want to tell me about cleomenes he's so cleomenes is really the first great character that we know about because herodotus writes about him and Herodotus the first historian is basically
但首先，我想谈谈——我们收到了太多的问题，汤姆。让我们直接来看看这些问题。其中有几个是关于个人的。其中一个重要人物就是克里昂米尼（Cleomenes）。乔纳森·梅策（Jonathan Metzer）问：“你能给我们讲讲克里昂米尼国王的扩张主义吗？他试图压制雅典的民主革命，被放逐、被召回、发疯、被监禁，然后被发现因伤死在拘禁中。他到底是怎么回事？”所以我对这个一无所知，你想给我讲讲克里昂米尼吗？克里昂米尼确实是我们所知道的第一位伟大人物，因为希罗多德写到了他，而作为第一位历史星的希罗多德，基本上
our main source well often our only source for early Sparta and it's clear that Herodotus has spoken to lots of different people about Cleomenes because he gives quite different perspectives on him Cleomenes is a king who rules for a very long time. And that means that he's able to build up quite a power base. And he's a very, he's an unusually imaginative and expansionist king. Spartans, the tradition is that they are very hidebound. Cleomenes seems not to have been. He plays kind of key roles in various developments in the decades before the persian invasions so he the the delphic oracle starts telling spartans go and um
是我们了解早期斯巴达的主要信息来源，嗯，通常也是唯一的来源。很明显，希罗多德曾与许多不同的人谈论过克里昂米尼，因为他对克里昂米尼的评价有着截然不同的视角。克里昂米尼是一位统治了很长时间的国王。这意味着他能够建立相当强大的权力基础。而且他是一个非常——一个不同寻常地富有想象力和扩张性的国王。传统上认为斯巴达人非常墨守成规，但克里昂米尼似乎并非如此。在波斯入侵前的几十年里，他在各种事态发展中发挥了关键作用。所以德尔斐神谕开始告诉斯巴达人去——呃，
chuck the tyrants out of athens so cleomenes does that um but he then gets terribly upset when the athenians decide they're going to set up a democracy. Yeah. And he tries to stop them. That all goes wrong. So that's that's a kind of blot on his copy book. The he he's encouraged. He gets asked by the Ionians who are Greeks who live on the other side of the Aegean to join in the revolt against the Persians, which ultimately the Athenians do join, which then results in the Battle of Marathon. So it's a disaster. Cleomenes works out that it's going to be a disaster. And he does that because he has a very sassy,
把暴君赶出雅典。于是克里昂米尼照做了——但随后，当雅典人决定建立民主制时，他变得极其愤怒。是的。他试图阻止他们。结果这一切都搞砸了。所以这是他履历上的一个污点。他受到了鼓舞。生活在爱琴海另一侧的希腊人爱奥尼亚人请求他加入反抗波斯的起义，雅典人最终也加入了这场起义，这随后导致了马拉松战役。所以这是一场灾难。克里昂米尼算出这将是一场灾难。他之所以能做到这一点，是因为他有一个非常时髦、
very intelligent, very smart daughter called Gorgo, who is actually the heroine of the children's book. No, of the children's book. Oh, right, okay. That I have just today finished before starting this. What a nice, it's a nice moment. And also a nice sort of anticipatory plug. That's very, yes, very kind very so gorgo is my narrator well congratulations according to but according to herodotus um this this ionian guy comes to try and persuade cleomenes and
非常聪明、非常机灵的女儿，名叫戈尔戈（Gorgo），她其实就是那本儿童书里的女主角。不，是那本儿童书里的。哦，对，好吧。我今天在开始录制这个之前刚刚读完。多好的一件事，这是一个美好的时刻。这也是一个很好的、带有预期性的软广。非常感谢，非常贴心。所以戈尔戈是我的叙述者——祝贺你！——但根据希罗多德的说法，——这个爱奥尼亚人来试图说服克里昂米尼，
cleomenes is almost swayed because the the ionian is saying oh if you conquer the persians you'll get so much money and gorgo says uh you know don't do it this is a terrible you know you're you're you're being um you're being bribed here um back off so cleomenes does so that's but the um he cleomenes is also the guy who chucks out the persian ambassadors down the well so people who've watched 300 will think you know in that leonidas does that but actually it's cleomenes who does that right um and the other thing that that cleomenes does is the only rival that sparta has in the peloponnese is argos which likewise has this incredible pedigree that's where heracles lived and so on um cleomenes absolutely smashes argos and he does it in in a um
而克里昂米尼几乎被打动了，因为那个爱奥尼亚人说：“哦，如果你征服了波斯人，你就会得到这么多的财富。”而戈尔戈说：“呃，你知道的，别这么做，这是一件可怕的事——你知道的，你正在被——你正在被贿赂——退下吧。”于是克里昂米尼照做了。所以那是——但克里昂米尼也是那个把波斯使者扔进井里的人——所以看过《300勇士》的人会以为那是列奥尼达（Leonidas）干的，但实际上是克里昂米尼干的，对吧？呃，克里昂米尼做的另一件事是，斯巴达在伯罗奔尼撒唯一的对手是阿尔戈斯（Argos），阿尔戈斯同样有着显赫的血统，那是赫拉克勒斯生活过的地方等等——克里昂米尼彻底粉碎了阿尔戈斯，他通过一种——
basically he pulverizes them loads of archives hide in a grove um clermont says that he'll he'll spare them if they come out of the grove some come out of the grave clermont kills them he then burns down the grove and this is a sacred grove and in due course Cleomenes goes mad yeah um he he takes to the hills um he starts raiding Sparta he opens up negotiations with the efforts to return comes back and he goes completely off his completely insane gets locked up in the stocks gets guarded by Helot the Helot walks into the shed where he's been locked up in the morning and finds that so insane is Cleomenes that he has taken a sharp knife.
基本上是把他们彻底消灭。许多阿尔戈斯人躲在一个树林里，克里昂米尼说只要他们走出树林就会饶他们不死。一些人走出了树林，克里昂米尼杀了他们，然后放火烧了这片树林。这是一片神圣的树林，不久之后，克里昂米尼就发疯了。是的，他逃到了山里，开始袭扰斯巴达，他与埃福尔（ephors）开启了返回的谈判，回国后却变得彻底不正常、完全疯了，被锁在木枷里，由一个黑劳士看守。第二天早上，黑劳士走进他被锁在里面的棚屋，发现克里昂米尼已经疯到这种程度：他拿了一把锋利的刀，
He's hacked the flesh off his toes, off his feet, off his calves, off his thighs, hacked open his groin, started to peel off all the flesh from his stomach and killed himself. And so Herodotus describes
把脚趾、双脚、小腿、大腿上的肉都割了下来，剖开腹股沟，开始剥掉肚子上的所有肉，然后自杀了。所以希罗多德描述了
this and he says you know there were many many disagreements about what could have caused this was it because Cleomenes had burnt down the sacred grove was it because he'd offended Demeter outside Athens was it because he'd done this was it because he'd done that what what Herodotus never asks is might he have been murdered yeah which is sort of the obvious yeah and if he was murdered then you know on the principle of qui bono who benefits the person who succeeds him is his half-brother yeah leonidas so that okay so leonidas yeah may well have the guilt of fratricide on his conscience but that's not what he's famous for he's famous for thermopylae he is gerard butler isn't he yes and uh you know i saw in modern sparta they have this fan you know 1960s but you know very admirable statue of him and he's the one spartan that most
这一切，他说（你知道的）关于导致这一切的原因有很多很多的争议：是因为克里昂米尼烧毁了神圣的树林吗？是因为他在雅典城外冒犯了得墨忒耳（Demeter）吗？是因为他做了这个吗？是因为他做了那个吗？希罗多德从未提出过的一个问题是：他会不会是被谋杀的呢？是的，这可以说是显而易见的。是的。如果他是被谋杀的，那么根据“谁受益”（cui bono）的原则，继承他的人是他的异母兄弟——是的，列奥尼达。所以好吧，所以列奥尼达——很可能良心上背负着弑兄的罪名。但这并不是他出名的原因。他因温泉关（Thermopylae）而闻名，他就是杰拉德·巴特勒（Gerard Butler），对吧？是的，呃，我看到在现代斯巴达，他们有这样一座粉丝——你知道的，20世纪60年代的，但非常令人钦佩的他的雕像，他是大多数人都听说过的唯一一个斯巴达人。我们稍后要做一个播客——我的意思是，我知道我们在很多话题上都这么说，但我们真的要做一个关于温泉关的播客。所以我们不会过多地深入……是的，因为这是温泉关之战2500周年。是的，所以我们必须这样做。所以我们绝对必须这样做。因此，温泉关的纪念日将在8月底到来，接着是9月份雅典城外的伟大海上胜利萨拉米斯（Salamis）战役。所以我们到时候会做这个。但作为一个开胃菜，迈克尔·伯德（Michael Bird）的问题是：
people have heard of we are going to do a podcast later i mean i mean i know that we say this about so many subjects but we genuinely are going to do a podcast about Thermopylae. So we won't go massively into... Yeah, because this is the 2500th anniversary of it. Yeah, so we have to. So we absolutely have to. So the anniversary of Thermopylae is coming up at the end of August and then of Salamis, the great naval victory outside
温泉关真的只有300名斯巴达人，手持斗篷、内裤、长矛和苏格兰口音，去对抗一百万波斯人吗？呃，不。好吧，人数不止300人，波斯人也没有——不，人数不止300人，军队也没有带来，汤姆，对的。人数确实不止300人。是的。所以情况是这样的——我们其实在聊奥运会时谈到过这个——
Athens in September. So we're going to do it then. But just as a sort of taster, Michael Bird's question. was thermopylae really 300 spartans fighting a million persians armed with nothing more than capes underpants spears and scottish accents um no well there were more than 300 nor did the nor were the persians no there were more than 300 nor did the army bring tom right there were more than 300 of them yeah so what happens is i mean we actually talked about this with the olympics is that
奥运会正在进行，所以伯罗奔尼撒人不能去，因为这会冒犯神明，但同样地，温泉关是进行牵制作战的理想地点。是的。所以300人去了，这是希庇阿斯（Hippias），这是国王的卫队，精锐部队。他们知道自己会死，因为只有生过儿子的才能去。所以他们知道自己面临着极高的死亡风险。他们带上了其他几千名伯罗奔尼撒人。他们在关隘附近与各种当地人汇合，并坚守阵地——列奥尼达在这场故事中发挥的巨大作用当然是——当波斯人最终绕过关隘来到斯巴达人后方时，他打发走了大多数其他军队。有一些人坚持与他并肩作战——
um the olympic games are going on and so the peloponnesians can't go because it will offend the gods but equally thermopylae is the ideal place to stage a holding operation yeah so the 300 go this is the hippias this is the the bodyguard of the king, the crack squad. They know they're going to die because only people who've had sons go. So they know that they're in kind of high risk of dying. They take about several thousand other Peloponnesians. They meet up with various locals around the pass and that they hold it um the the the outsized role that Leonidas plays in this story is of course that um when the Persians end up going round the pass and come down in the Spartans rear he sends most of the other troops away there are some that that
他们就是那些往往不被人们记住的人，塞斯比人（Thespians），是的，还有一些底比斯人。正是这300人的坚守，是的，这被人们纪念，而且确实我认为这就是让人对斯巴达感到狂热的原因。是的，被恋物癖化了，不是吗？嗯，这就是——你知道的，斯巴达有太多让人感到恐怖和害怕的东西，我认为对他们的这种恐惧和敬畏也正是让他们着迷的原因。我的意思是，我小时候非常迷恋恐龙，
insist on standing with him they they are the ones who don't tend to be remembered the thespians yes and some thebans as well um it's it's the stand of the 300 yeah it is um that that is commemorated and really is i think what thrills people about sparta yes fetishized isn't it this time well it's you know there's there's so much that's that's terrifying and frightening about Sparta and I think that the terror and the fear of them is also what makes them fascinating I mean I when I was a child I was you know hugely into dinosaurs
而兽脚亚目恐龙、异特龙、迅猛龙、霸王龙等各种恐龙的壮观景象，你知道的，我当时觉得非常刺激，我觉得思考斯巴达也能给我带来非常——非常相似的感受。小孩子就是喜欢那样——我的意思是，我儿子当我们去度假时，你知道的，他买了一他吵着要买斯巴达T恤，他带回了一个小型的列奥尼达雕像，他
and the spectacle of you know theropods allosaurs, velociraptors, whatever tyrannosaurs was you know I found it thrilling and I found contemplating sparta gave me something very you know very similar children like that i mean my son when we went on holiday you know he bought he he demanded spartan t-shirts he he's brought home a little statue of leonidas he he
这一切都爱不释手。我的意思是，雅典人——当我跟他说雅典的哲学、诗歌时，我的意思是，他根本不在乎这些东西。那种作为战士进行训练和战斗的想法，才是让小男孩们感兴趣的东西。对，对。所以这让他们显得可怕、吓人而且带有一种迷人的魅力。是的。但是列奥尼达——列奥尼达被塑造成一个为自己城市的自由和希腊而死的人，因此这使他在希腊历史上占据了极其重要的地位。所以——他（你知道的）他的节日甚至在整个罗马时期都被庆祝。对，我的意思是，甚至连奥利金（Origen）——这位伟大的亚历山大里亚教会之父、基督教
loves all that i mean the athenians i when i say to him athens philosophy poetry i mean he could give a damn about those things. The thought of sort of training and fighting as a warrior, that's what gets small boys interested. Right, right. So that makes them frightening and terrifying and kind of glamorous. Yeah. But what Leonidas, Leonidas is cast as a man who dies for the freedom of his city and for greece and that therefore has given him an outsized role through greek history so um he you know his festival is celebrated throughout roman times right i mean even even say origin the great church father the alexandrian um christian
学者——他将基督与列奥尼达进行了比较。这太迷人了！所以他不是好莱坞的发明，他不是现代的发明。如果他真的是被发明出来的，那他也是一个历史久远得多的存在，你知道的。然后——然后当这个故事在文艺复兴时期被重新发现时，你有了蒙田（Montaigne），他说温泉关的失败比马拉松、萨拉米斯或普拉提亚（Plataea）的所有胜利都要崇高得多。你有了拜伦（Byron）：
uh teacher he compares uh christ delaney does that's fascinating so he's not his life so he's not a hollywood invention he's not a modern invention he was if he is an invention at all he's a much older one you know and then and then when this story gets rediscovered in the renaissance you you have montaigne who says that um the the defeat at thermopylae is much nobler than all you know the victories at marathon or salamis or platea um you famous you have byron um earth render back from out thy breast a remnant of our spartan dead of the 300 grant but three to make a new thermopylae and that clearly inspires him to go and fight for greece and to die for greek freedom and and you've
“大地，从你的胸膛中/交还斯巴达死士的遗骸/哪怕在三百人中只许诺三个/也能成就一个新的温泉关”——这显然激发了他去为希腊战斗，去为希腊的自由而死。并且你有了威廉·戈尔丁（William Golding）的一篇著名散文，他去了温泉关，并说我所享受的一小部分自由要归功于列奥尼达。而这当然与斯巴达人基本上就是纳粹的这种看法形成了对立面——因为当然，具有讽刺意味的是，如果斯巴达人曾被波斯人征服，波斯人就会做底比斯人后来所做的事，那就是解放美西尼亚人，而美西尼亚人在波斯统治下过上的自由生活，会比他们在斯巴达统治下过上的生活要多得多。好吧，让我们稍后再来聊聊种族主义和法西斯主义的问题。显而易见的那头房间里的大象，
got this kind of famous essay by william golding who goes to the hot gates and and and says that a little part of little part of the freedom that i enjoy is due to leonidas and that of course is the counterpoint to the sense of the spartans as basically nazis because of course the the irony is is that if the Spartans had had if Sparta had been conquered by the Persians the Persians would have done what the Thebans subsequently did which is to liberate the Messenians and the Messenians would have been would have led a much more free life under Persia than they would have done under Sparta. Okay well let's come on to the racism and fascism questions a bit later. The obvious sort of elephant
我们还没聊的就是雅典——所以斯巴达在现代人的想象中就像是雅典的对立面，不是吗？这有点像列侬和麦卡特尼（Lennon and McCartney）之类的，或者说（你知道的）你无法想象没有其中一个的另一个。好吧，这就是美国和俄罗斯，这是美苏冷战，这是《洛奇4》，这是德拉戈（Drago）和西尔维斯特·史泰龙（Sylvester Stallone）。完全正确。除了西尔维斯特·史泰龙不是——我的意思是，他不是个伟大的哲学家，对吧？不，他不是。我们才是伟大的诗人。好吧，我想是的。
in the room we haven't talked about is athens so sparta kind of works in the modern imagination as a counterpoint to athens doesn't it it's a bit like lennon and mccarney or something or you know you can't imagine one without the other well it's it's america and russia it's american soviet union the cold war it's rocky four it's uh drago and uh sylvester stallone. That's exactly right. Except Sylvester Stallone isn't, I mean, he's not a great philosopher, is he? No, he's not. We're great poets. Well, I guess.
好，所以马修·希斯邦特（Matthew Hisbunt）说：“斯巴达、雅典、苏格兰、英格兰。每当互相争吵时总是很高兴。总是准备着互相大打出手，直到一个共同的敌人——波斯——似乎把他们暂时团结起来，以保卫家园。”但在我看来——我并不是在敲打马修·希斯邦特——但事实恰恰相反，不是吗？共同的防御在
Right, so Matthew Hisbunt says, Sparta, Athens, Scotland, England. Always happy when squabbling with each other. Always ready to knock spots off each other until a common enemy, Persia, seems to unite them temporarily to defend hearth and home. But that seems to me i'm not knocking matthew hispant but it's the other way around isn't it that the the common defense comes
伯罗奔尼撒战争之前就出现了，正是在那场战争中——所以伯罗奔尼撒战争，斯巴达赢了——我的意思是，那基本上结束了雅典的辉煌时期——为什么当斯巴达如此强大时，其他希腊城市不站在雅典这一边呢？是因为他们害怕斯巴达，还是因为他们对雅典的怨恨和猜忌，远比现代的“雅典迷”们所想象的要多得多？好吧，基本上是因为雅典野心过大，以至于它发动了一场完全流产的远征，目标是西西里。是的。那是阿尔西比亚德斯（Alcibiades）干的，对吧？是这样吗？
before the peloponnesian war which is when they when they so the peloponnesian war um sparta wins that i mean basically that ends athens's period of glory um why why did the other greek cities not side with athens when sparta is so is it because they're frightened of sparta or is it because they are much more resentful and suspicious of athens than sort of modern you know athena files would would imagine well basically athens overreaches itself so it launches this completely abortive invasion of Sicily. Yeah. That's Alcibiades who does that, is it? Is that right?
好吧，阿尔西比亚德斯——同样地，我们之前在奥运会上聊过，他在战车赛中赢得了前三名。他在雅典被指控不敬神。基本上，他就是西西里远征背后的那个人。但他最终逃跑了。他最终去了斯巴达。他向斯巴达人出谋划策，告诉他们雅典人最不愿意看到的事。基本上，雅典的战争机器从那以后就开始瓦解了。而且令人难以置信的是，斯巴达能够把自己塑造为自由的捍卫者，尽管它显然不是。
Well, Alcibiades is, again, we talked about in the Olympics, he wins the top three places in the chariot race. He gets accused of impiety in Athens. And basically, he's the guy behind the Sicilian invasion. But he ends up fleeing. And he ends up in Sparta. And he advises the Spartans on what to do, the things that the Athenians would least like. And basically, the Athenian war effort kind of crumbles away after that. And amazingly, Sparta is able to cast itself as the defender of freedom, even though it obviously isn't.
当雅典的城墙伴随着长笛声被推倒时，人们说这是希腊自由开始的日子。因为斯巴达是一个残暴的军国主义强权，坚持要按自己的意愿行事，它那种——你知道的——本能地想要压制几乎所有与它对抗的人。它可能无法把他们全变成黑劳士，但它绝对想要压制他们。因此，在伯罗奔尼撒战争之后，它的力量直接烟消云散了。而令人惊奇的是，仅仅几十年内，雅典人就卷土重来了。他们的舰队恢复到了正常运转的状态。并且你有了底比斯，这三大城市中的第三个，在这之前它一直都是——底比斯的大多数人实际上都站在了波斯人一边。
And when the walls of Athens are pulled down to pipes, people say this is the day for the beginning of freedom of Greece. because Sparta is a kind of brutal militarist power that insists on having its own way, that kind of, you know, it instinctively wants to subordinate almost everybody that it comes up against. It can't reduce them to heritage, but it certainly wants to subordinate them. And so in the aftermath of the Peloponnesian War, its power just melts away. And amazingly, within just a few decades, the Athenians are back. They've got their fleet back up in working order. And you've got Thebes, the third of these great cities, which up till then had always been. So the majority of Thebans sided with the Persians.
这是斯巴达人和雅典人永远不会忘记的事情。但你拥有了这样一位——绝对堪称天才的将军，名叫伊巴密浓达（Epaminondas），他彻底重新校准了军事战略，并且能够击败斯巴达的战争机器，而这台战争机器在此之前一直是不败的。在公元前371年的留克特拉（Leuctra）战役中，发生了一场大战，斯巴达不可战胜的神话被彻底粉碎了。斯巴达人试图重组他们的军队。但同样地，他们在公元前362年一个叫做曼丁尼亚（Mantinea）的地方——实际上是在伯罗奔尼撒——再次被击溃，这基本上就结束了。因为正如我所说，底比斯人解放了美西尼亚人，从那时起，斯巴达就彻底完蛋了。但是，汤姆，退一步讲，当他们在伯罗奔尼撒战争结束时成为顶级强国、顶级希腊城邦时，他们为什么没有变成罗马呢？
And that's something that the Spartans and athenians never let them forget but you you have this um this general of absolute genius called epaminondas who radically recalibrates um military strategy and is able to defeat the spartan war machine which up until that point had been invincible and there is this great battle um at Leuctra in 371 where the myth of Spartan invincibility is completely shattered. And the Spartans try and kind of reconstitute their army. But again, they're kind of shattered at a place called Mantinea, actually in the Peloponnese in 362 and and that essentially is it because you know as I said the the Thebans liberate the Messenians and from that point on Sparta is is a busted flush but Tom to backtrack a little bit when they were top top nation top or top Greek city-state at the end of the Peloponnesian War, why didn't they become Rome?
为什么他们没有像罗马人那样做，基本上是粉碎所有邻国、吞并它们或者别的什么，并让军事征服的势头带着他们从一场胜利走向另一场胜利呢？为什么斯巴达做不到这一点？因为吕库古宪法的全部基础在于：你有一个坐在火山之上的斯巴达精英阶层。我的意思是，基本上就是这样，对吧？而斯巴达人极其保守，他们对这部宪法感到无比自豪，因此他们拒绝做出改变。奇怪的是——你知道的——在通往斯巴达被罗马帝国吞并的漫长岁月中，他们始终认为解决自身问题的答案是回归这部吕库古宪法。
Why didn't they do what the Romans did, which is basically crush all their neighbours, absorb them or whatever, and the momentum of military conquest just carry them from victory to victory? Why didn't Sparta manage to do that? Because the whole basis of the Lycurgian constitution is that you have a Spartan elite sitting atop a volcano I mean that's basically it right and the Spartans are incredibly conservative and they're incredibly proud of this constitution and so they refuse to change it and the strange thing is is that you know all the way all the way through the centuries that lead up to the the absorption of Sparta into the Roman Empire, they assume that the answer to their problems is to go back to this Lycurgian constitution.
所以你看到了一次又一次试图将其重焕生机的尝试。人们想要相信它。因此，西塞罗（Cicero）评价斯巴达人时说，他们是世界上唯一一个生活在习俗和法律长达700年未变的人群。我的意思是，这并不是真的，但斯巴达人能够让罗马人相信事实确实如此，而人们也愿意相信它。事实上，斯巴达是不变的这一观念，是将其视为“海市蜃楼”的关键部分。这既是斯巴达人想要相信的，也是局外人想要相信的关键部分。好吧。好吧。我接受这一点。说到这里，顺便过渡一下关于局外人如何看待斯巴达人的问题，有很多关于种族主义和法西斯主义的问题。这里有一个很好的例子。为《星期日泰晤士报》撰稿的乔什·格兰西（Josh Glancy）问了我们一个问题：
So you have repeated attempts to try and reanimate it. And people want to believe in it. So Cicero says of the Spartans that they're the only people in the world who have lived, you know, with customs and laws that have been unchanged for 700 years. I mean, this isn't true, but the Spartans are able to kind of convince the Romans that this is the case and people want to believe it. And actually, the idea that that Sparta is unchanging is a crucial part of this you know, of this idea of it as a mirage. It's a crucial part of both what the Spartans want to believe and therefore what outsiders want to believe. Okay. Okay. I buy that. So talking of a nice segue here about what outsiders think of the Spartans, there are a ton of questions about racism and fascism. So here's a good example. Josh Glancy, who writes for the Sunday Times times has asked us a is it in any way
将斯巴达人描述为法西斯主义者或准法西斯主义者，在任何方面是准确的还是具有历史相关性的？我们收到了很多问题。“悖论狂”（Paradoxymoron）说：“他们应该因为对黑劳士的残忍而被取消资格（被取消）吗？”还有人问：“斯巴达是历史上最具种族主义色彩的国家吗？”所以，首先，关于法西斯主义，把他们称为法西斯主义者毫无意义。至于种族主义，正如我所说——我认为这是一种安于现状的、时代的错置的看法，你知道的——正如我所说，整个事情的实质是，实际上黑劳士——你知道的——是同一拨人，对，那就是关键所在。他们是法西斯主义者吗？好吧，这也是把问题弄反了。
accurate or historically relevant to describe the spartans as fascist or as proto-fascist we've had lots of questions paradoxy moron says should they be cancelled because of their cruelty to the helots sirs further was sparta the most racist state in history so you know first of all fascism are they it doesn't make any sense to well them as fascists so on the racism you know as i i don't i think that's an anachronistic yeah way of seeing it and you know as i said the whole thing is is that actually the helots you know are it's the same people yes that's the that's the point um are they fascist well again that's kind of putting it the wrong way wrong way around
更恰当的问法应该是：斯巴达身上是否有某种法西斯主义的色彩？我会说：毫无疑问，是的。纳粹绝对对此着迷。绝对如此。你知道的，希特勒——希特勒说，黑汤——著名的斯巴达菜肴——最初来自石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因（Schleswig-Holstein），你最喜欢的德国州。它来自哪里，多米尼克？石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因，汤姆。看，我现在不经意间就能完美地说出它了。但还有一个因素，不是吗？
is is there something of sparta and fascism would be the better way of yes putting it and i would say indisputably yeah um the nazis definitely were fascinated absolutely um you know hitler hitler says that the black broth, the famous Spartan dish, originally came from Schleswig-Holstein, your favourite German state. Where did it come from, Dominic? Schleswig-Holstein, Tom. See, I can say it perfectly now when I'm not thinking about it. But there's also an element, isn't there,
不仅仅是纳粹对斯巴达着迷。所以我们收到了一些关于维多利亚时代英国的问题，例如斯巴达美德、阿诺德博士（Dr. Arnold）与橄榄球学校以及公立学校传统。我的意思是，这其中有很多都归功于对斯巴达的浪漫化，不是吗？所以我觉得可以这么说，按现代标准来看，斯巴达人相当右翼，对吧？但正如我所说，他们——你知道的——他们在左翼也有很大的支持基础。全民教育的理念——托马斯·莫尔（Thomas More）在《乌托邦》（Utopia）中就采纳了这一点。卢梭是个大——卢梭非常热爱斯巴达。
that it's not just the Nazis who are fascinated by Sparta. So we had a couple of questions about Victorian Britain, example Spartan virtues Dr Arnold and rugby school and the the public school tradition I mean a lot of that owes something to a romance of Sparta doesn't it so I think it's fair to say that by contemporary standards the the Spartans were quite right wing right but as I said they they you know they have a a big constituency on the left as well and the idea that of universal education yeah is one that thomas moore in utopia picks up on yeah russo was a big russo love the sparsity yeah um so the specific model of the boarding school of taking boys away when they're seven and toughening them up um you know putting them into the equivalent of houses uh making them play ferocious degrees of sport yeah um this is
所以，寄宿学校的具体模式——在七岁时将男孩们带走并锤炼他们，你知道的，把他们编入相当于宿舍的机构中，让他们进行极其残酷的体育运动——这
you know an overt influence on the way that public schools in 19th century britain develop um so the the you know the influences are manifold yeah and when people use the word spartan it's not always a pejorative is it you know no it's kind of austere it's austere but that's self-disciplined yeah it's pure um it's clean it's all those and of course that's not luxurious that that's not decadent no and that's the opposite of decadent and that plays into both victorianism and and fascism, I would say. Now, 300. We said we'd come to 300, and here we are.
（你知道的）是对19th世纪英国公立学校发展的一种显而易见的深远影响。所以这些影响是多方面的。当人们使用“斯巴达式的”这个词时，它并不总是一个贬义词，不是吗？不，它代表着简朴。它是简朴的，但那是自律的。它是纯粹的，它是干净的，它是所有这些。当然，那不是奢侈的，那不是颓废的。不，那是颓废的反面，我认为这既符合维多利亚主义，也符合法西斯主义。现在，谈到《300勇士》。我们说过我们会聊到《300勇士》，现在我们来了。
So 300, Frank Miller, the comic book writer, has seen a film from the 1950s, I think, or early 60s, I can't remember which, about... 300 Spartans. Yeah, about Thermopylae, and it sticks in his mind, and he goes on to do this comic book, which some people have seen as fascist actually and they see the film as quite fascistic so talk to me about the film because i know you've
所以《300勇士》，漫画作家弗兰克·米勒（Frank Miller）看过一部20世纪50年代或60年代初（我记不清具体是哪个了）的电影，讲述的是……《斯巴达三百勇士》。是的，关于温泉关，这留在了他的脑海里，于是他创作了这部漫画，有些人实际上认为这部漫画非常法西斯，他们也认为这部电影带有相当浓厚的法西斯色彩。所以跟我聊聊这部电影吧，因为我知道你写过关于它的文章。你觉得这部电影是一部伟大的——我的意思是，我知道你是这部电影作为古希腊愿景的超级粉丝——
written about it do you think the film is a great you i mean i know you're a big fan of the film as a vision of ancient greece yeah so so i the huge problem with most films about antiquity is is that they have to import anachronism because otherwise the audience will be alienated. So traditionally the way that you do that is you bring in a Christian slave, gladiator films. You always have a Christian slave. Well,
所以，大多数关于古代的电影都有一个巨大的问题，那就是它们必须引入时代的错置，否则观众就会感到疏离。传统上，你实现这一目标的方式是通过引入一个基督教奴隶，比如角斗士电影。你总是会有一个基督教奴隶。或者，
you think of gladiator. It's a kind of liberal Senator who wants to restore the Republic, which is kind of equated with liberal democracy. So the Derek Jacoby character in gladiator, which is entirely bogus. You know, this bogus you know this is you know there were no equivalents of liberals in the classical world um what what 300 does is unapologetically to present the world in the way that um the Spartans did um and so 300 I think is absolutely the kind of film that the you know know, the F4s, if they had been presented, it would have allowed to screen in Spartan. but what it does is to say that um if you are you know if you're if you're handsome if you're ripped
想想《角斗士》。里面有一个自由派参议员，他想要恢复共和国，这在某种程度上被等同于自由民主。所以《角斗士》里德里克·雅各比（Derek Jacoby）的角色完全是伪造的。你知道的，这种虚假的——你知道的，古典世界里根本没有自由派的对应物。而《300勇士》所做的，是毫不掩饰地以斯巴达人看待世界的方式来呈现世界。因此，我认为《300勇士》绝对是那种——如果埃福尔（ephors）存在的话——会被允许在斯巴达上映的电影。但它所做的是在说：
if you have a kind of amazing physique then you're a good person if you're physically ugly if you're deformed then you're not you're you're morally deformed as well so um in in 300 effialti is the guy who who betrays the past of thermopylae and leads the Persians around the rear. He is portrayed as this hunchback, this cripple who wants to become a Spartan warrior. And if this was a Tom Hanks film, that's what would happen. He would join the band of brothers and he would do something heroic
如果你——如果你长得英俊，如果你肌肉健美，如果你有着惊人的体魄，那么你就是一个好人。如果你身体丑陋，如果你畸形，那么你不仅不是好人，你在道德上也是畸形的。所以，在《300勇士》中，埃菲阿尔特（Ephialtes）就是那个背叛温泉关隘口并引领波斯人绕到后方的人。他被塑造成一个驼背、一个渴望成为斯巴达战士的残疾人。如果这是一部汤姆·汉克斯（Tom Hanks）的电影，事情就会是那样的。他会加入兄弟连，他会做一些英勇的事情，
and he'd probably die saving the platoon or something like that. Be tear-jerking. But in this, he's as morally contemptible as he's physically ugly and it's kind of shocking and the other way in which um you know the film opens with the with the apothecary with the um the the the ravine where the babies are chucked down a cliff and it this is the voiceover saying that you know to be span, you have to be strong. And it's unapologetically saying infanticide is a great thing because it'll make for better soldiers.
他可能会通过拯救排里的人而牺牲，或者类似的剧情。会非常感人催泪。但在片中，他在道德上的卑劣正如他在形体上的丑陋一样，这让人感到震惊。电影开场的另一种方式是——伴随着药剂师的旁白——也就是那个把婴儿扔下悬崖的峡谷——画外音说，要想成为斯巴达人，你必须强壮。它毫不掩饰地说杀婴是一件大好事，因为这能培养出更好的士兵。
Yeah. So I think, you know, on one level, you could say that's very fascist. But on the other, you could say that's completely true to the myth that the Spartans propagated about themselves. So I think it's I mean, I do think it is an incredible by our standards an incredibly fascist film but i think that is what makes it kind of true true yeah to how the greek how the spartans saw the world or at least how the greeks saw the spartans and and here's an interesting thing tom because i mean you're a great man you know you've gone through the whole podcast you've gone through the whole podcast without mentioning really Christianity.
所以我觉得，一方面，你可以说这非常法西斯。但另一方面，你可以说这完全符合斯巴达人对自己大肆宣扬的神话。所以我觉得——我的意思是，我的确认为按我们的标准来看，这是一部极其法西斯主义的电影，但我认为正是这一点，让它变得非常真实——真实地反映了希腊人——或者说希腊人如何看待斯巴达人。还有一个有趣的事情，汤姆——因为我的意思是，你是个伟大的人——你知道的，你通篇录制了整个播客，你录完了整个播客，却没有真正提到基督教。
And Christianity is kind of cult of the victim and, you know, the sort of Harry and Meghan side of Christianity, the kind of compassion and stuff. And it's weird, isn't it, how the Sparta has endured, the glamour of Sparta has endured, despite the fact that it runs completely counter to the tradition that you think has defined Western culture for the last 2000 years. I mean, I mentioned origin in the in the third century when the second century that the Jews were in revolt and trying to establish a kind of independent state. The high priest wrote to the king of Sparta and said, you know, we are kin. You too are descended from Moses. date the high priest wrote to the king of sparta and said you know we we are kin uh you you too are descended from moses that's right which are weird i don't think i don't think the nazis kind of majored on that no um so there was a even i mean jews and christians were obsessed by sparta as well and i think the the appeal of sparta is, you know, we were talking before, that it's fierce and it's glamorous and they're brave. There's a bit of a Spartan inside all of us, isn't there?
而基督教某种程度上是受害者崇拜，你知道的，类似于基督教中哈里和梅根（Harry and Meghan）的那一面，那种同情心之类的事物。很奇怪，不是吗？尽管斯巴达完全违背了你认为在过去两千年里定义了西方文化的传统，但斯巴达的魅力却经久不衰。我的意思是，我提到了公元三世纪的奥利金——当二世纪犹太人起义并试图建立一个独立国家时，大祭司给斯巴达国王写信说：“我们是亲属。你们也是摩西的后代。”等等，大祭司给斯巴达国王写信说：“我们——我们是亲属，呃，你们也是摩西的后代。”没错。这真的很奇怪，我不认为纳粹会在这一点上大做文章。所以，犹太人和基督徒也对斯巴达着迷。我认为斯巴达的吸引力在于，正如我们之前谈到的，它既凶猛又迷人，而且他们很勇敢。每个人的内心深处其实都有一个斯巴达人，不是吗？
Maybe not all of us, but I think there's more of a Spartan inside us than lots of people would like to think. There's not a Spartan inside Jeremy Corbyn. But I think there's a Spartan inside most of us have got an inner Spartan somewhere even if we try to keep them at bay yeah I mean I think that the the kind of model of extreme heroism yeah and I use you know heroism in the Greek sense that that the Greeks saw in the Spartans is something that is able to kind of inspire maybe grudging admiration. But it's about manliness. Certainly a fascination.
也许不是所有人，但我认为我们每个人内心深处的斯巴达人，要比许多人愿意承认的还要多。杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）的内心深处可没有斯巴达人。但我认为我们大多数人的内心深处都有一个内在的斯巴达人，即使我们试图将他们克制住。是的，我的意思是，我认为极端英雄主义的模式——我在这里使用的是希腊语意义上的英雄主义，即希腊人在斯巴达人身上看到的那种英雄主义——是一种能够激发人们——哪怕是勉强——敬佩的东西。但这也是关于男子气概的。当然是一种迷恋。
It's manliness as well, isn't it? Do you not think? It is. Well, of course, yes. I mean, it is. It's a very. But, you know, the other paradox about Sparta is that it's probably the best place to be a woman. OK. So, you know, the other paradox about Sparta is that it's probably the best place to be a woman. OK.
这也是关于男子气概的，不是吗？你不这么认为吗？确实是。当然，是的。我的意思是，它是。这是一个非常——但你知道的，关于斯巴达的另一个悖论是，它可能是作为女性最好的地方。好吧。所以，你知道的，关于斯巴达的另一个悖论是，它可能是作为女性最好的地方。好吧。
So, you know, I mean, that's that is it's a city that that's absolutely full of paradoxes. It's it's a highly masculine city in which the women are freer than anywhere else, certainly more than in Athens it's it's a city where um masters sit on top of a kind of pile of of of inferiors and yet themselves live like slaves um it's it's a a city where um people live you know that they have to live like everybody else and yet at the same time it's absolutely based on ruthless competition so it's this kind of bundle of paradoxes that makes it kind of infinitely fascinating and I think it's really interesting that when we asked for questions for this i mean we got hundreds and hundreds this and that's always a measure of how you know how much potency a field in history has i think um it's a great note on which to end tom um the top ancient
所以，你知道的，我的意思是——这是一个绝对充满悖论的城市。它是一个高度雄性化的城市，但那里的女性却比其他任何地方都更加自由，绝对比在雅典更自由。它是一个——大师们高高坐在劣等阶层堆积如山之上的城市，然而他们自己却过着奴隶般的生活。它是一个——人们必须像其他人一样生活的城市，然而与此同时，它却绝对建立在残酷的竞争基础之上。所以正是这种种种悖论的结合，让它变得拥有无限的迷人之处。我认为非常有趣的是，当我们为此征集问题时——我的意思是，我们收到了成百上千个问题——这总是衡量历史领域具有多大潜力的标准，我认为——这是一个很棒的结束语，汤姆——最顶尖的古代
world classical history pundit tom holland has proclaimed sparta land of contrasts so and if you'd like to read more about it uh persian fire by me oh that was shocking shops and my translation of herodotus for penguin classics is also available he i mean i said earlier on you had no shame and i was absolutely right but the spartan we did a whole episode for you that's ancient history right um so well done tom jolly good um i like the spartans personally i think the athenians are a bit of feet and weedy and you astonish me yeah um the spartans would have been um that they'd have been daily mail readers wouldn't they they absolutely would have been they're not guardian people right on that note uh we shall see you next time with
世界古典历史专家汤姆·霍兰曾宣称斯巴达是“对比鲜明之地”，所以如果您想了解更多关于它的信息，呃，有我写的《波斯战火》——哦，这广告太生硬了——我为企鹅经典翻译的希罗多德著作也已上市。我的意思是，我刚才说过你毫无廉耻，我完全说对了，但斯巴达人，我们为你做过一整期节目，那是《那是古代历史》，对吧？嗯，干得好，汤姆，好样的。我个人挺喜欢斯巴达人的，我觉得雅典人有点软弱无力。你让我大吃一惊。是的，呃，斯巴达人会是那种会阅读《每日邮报》的人，对吧？他们绝对会是的，他们可不是会看《卫报》的人。好了，说到这里，呃，我们下期再见，带着
we've got a lot of nuclear war yeah nuclear a lot of cold war stuff coming time with we've got a lot of nuclear Berlin Wall yeah nuclear a lot of Cold War stuff coming up and we've got stuff about exams bizarrely you might think but a really fascinating subject
我们有很多核战争的内容，对，核战争，有很多冷战的内容接下来会播出，柏林墙，对，核战争，有很多冷战的内容要来，我们还有关于考试的内容，你可能会觉得很奇怪，但这其实是一个非常迷人的主题
so we've got lots of good stuff and we will see you next time and I'll do more of the talking next time goodbye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们有很多精彩的内容，我们下期再见，下次我会多说一点，再见，拜拜，拜拜。感谢收听《历史余音》，获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告收听等福利。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。